[Music]
[Applause]
special hour on CBS this morning I'm 22
copal I've got Gayle King here I've got
Anthony Mason here and we've got
everyone else in this studio we were
joined by a live studio audience as we
talked about a very important topic
mental illness mental wellness mount
wellness and mental health and the
journey between the three now get this
one in six young people experienced a
mental health disorder each year and the
suicide rate for adolescents aged 10 to
14 has nearly tripled in the last decade
think about that for a second a little
ten-year-old person up to 14 that's very
scary stuff me Anna Bryant was diagnosed
with depression back in college she
didn't know where to turn so she created
her own support group for college
students to talk with each other about
their mental health she called it I like
this name Jana the mental elephant
[Music]
extremely scared to tell my family and
to tell my parents that I've been
diagnosed with depression and that I was
asked to be put on medication I didn't
want people to lose respect for me or to
look at me or treat me any different
than how they normally would
hello everyone welcome to our leading
sentimental elephant began when I first
received my diagnosis we're for everyone
who is not okay
but doesn't know how to get back to the
where they want to be the main thing I
like about the mental elephant it just
makes you feel welcome first and
foremost it just helps people talk we do
group chats we do empowerment events we
do study sessions people understand like
counseling is okay I do talk about it
too like my friends sometimes I'm still
working on that I know that there are
going to be days where you think your
world is collapsing there's going to be
moments where you're not even sure how
are you going to be able to get through
the current sixty Seconds the only thing
that you on this earth 100% have to do
[Applause]
with he is the medical director at the
National Alliance on Mental Illness one
of our consultants and the specialist in
Child and Adolescent Psychiatry good
morning to you both
me on that line you have at the end
there is very powerful sometimes you
just got to breathe what we did putting
this group together how did that help
you in the end all this group of friends
it helped me by providing me with
insight on how other people might have
to go through life and the things that
they experienced in college but it also
provided me with support and it allowed
me to provide other people with support
and everyone knows that giving and
providing other people with help is
something that can even help you in the
long run and allow you to feel great on
the inside this at East Carolina this
group now is 300 strong yes sir we have
elephants I'll call
you say we have elephants all over I'm
assuming it you named it for the
elephant in the room which I think is
very very clever well but something that
she yes ma'am so you're from the south
but Ken I thought she said something
very interesting that she was reluctant
to go to her parents and her friends
yeah because she didn't want them to
lose respect for her yeah that's exactly
why we're having this conversation why
we're delighted at Nami that you're
doing this yeah let me start by saying
me Ana's generation is changing this
game how so
openness vulnerability the willingness
to share things jnana is a beautiful
example of how the next generation you
think we're at a tipping point we are
absolutely at a tipping point in our
society people are talking about it
people are seeking help hardly a day
goes by so that somebody doesn't ask me
to connect them with a clinician but but
suicidal thoughts are going up among
young people yes first of time that's
right even as this generation is paving
the way for price going up Ken social
media is an opportunity to feel
humiliated every day yes yeah school
shooting drills should not be part of
sixth grade what they are in virtually
every school in America the design to
raise anxiety and we're losing five
Americans every hours our to the opiate
crisis Leon I'd use those kids know
somebody you sense a change at all in
your friends in terms of of the
reluctance in the past to talk about
this yes I would definitely say that
over the past at least two to three
years my friends and a lot of my family
members have become a lot more open and
honest and translucent when it comes to
their mental health and allowing me to
express myself and the things that I may
go through okay how do you tell the
difference I mean with all these people
you're talking to on a daily basis and
patients that you're seeing when does a
person know that they don't have
run-of-the-mill blues yes they have
something else that's gonna need a more
serious look at or more serious health
it's a great question Tony because all
of this experience anxiety all of us
experience sadness so it's easy to fall
into the trap of all you're just having
sadness or anxiety snap out of it that's
the wrong way to think about it when
these symptoms impact your functioning
trouble going to work your relationships
that's
sign and they persist for weeks that's a
sign that you might want to get an
independent mental health evaluation
another piece is sleep if you're waking
up at 4 o'clock in the morning it's
quite likely that you either have an
anxiety or a depressive disorder not if
you get up to do the good miss your
point is there anything jnana that
somebody could have said to you that
would have made a difference when you
were in the dark place I would
definitely say that the biggest thing
somebody could have said to me and I
would say to anyone now that may be in
that dark place is to keep breathing and
to quote my favorite movie Finding Nemo
just keep swimming just keep swimming
and try the best that you can no matter
what's going on we need to poo in
Finding Nemo having big rolls yeah one
more thing for Ken you said we were
talking yesterday most people who have
attempted suicide who survived regret
that they tried it IV regret that they
tried many people who said during an
impulsive act moment of desperation they
wish they had ended it all and then of
course upon reflection they know that
they can get help yes it can and does
get better thank you both thank you both
[Applause]